Come on, boy, boy, boo!
Johnny!
Stop it!
Oh my god!
He's...
Yes!
Stop it!
Ew!
My cat is going insane!
Stop!
No!
Don't look at me like that.
He's stalking me right now.
I see you!
Hold on, I think I have to chase him under the couch real
quick.
One second.
Johnny, go!
Go!
Yeah, go!
Okay.
We're fine.
I'm sorry, sometimes he gets into moods.
And he he's been good the past couple of streams.
But sometimes he just wants to run around and play.
And he kind of gets like weird fixations or like oh gosh he
sometimes will get a fixation with like with like uh going
under my bed has been one uh going in between the the doors
has been one like you know when a door is open and it's
against the wall he'll go behind that and then um now he has
a with being chased under the couch.
So he currently make...
What?
Oh, but sorry.
Right before stream, he discovered.
So I have a curtain.
I have like a curtain behind me for like when I record and
stuff.
And I need stuff to be really, uh...
Like soundproof.
And he's discovered that he can run into that.
And so if you hear my trash can just go and like...
That's him.
Running into the curtain, as he just learned, like two
minutes ago.
Thank you guys for the super chat, Spank.
Thanks to somebody, I discovered Extra Toasty Cheez-It's now
what am I to do with all the regular ones?
You are so welcome.
Welcome to the world of Toasty Cheez-It's.
Hello, Vito.
Johnny and I are just like you.
Johnny, be kind to our Vito.
Take it easy, Yoder.
Yes, he loves to be chased.
I got Vexbo meet and greet.
Thank you!
Oh, thank you, Vexbo!
Wait, that's so soon, too.
Let's go!
I mean, though, I adopted a cat today!
It's a little orange boy.
I love him.
G.A., congrats!
Practicing stealth and CQC.
Perfect MGS cat.
Well, now I have to play because of the Densetsu...
The Densetsu fundraiser we did yesterday, which thank you
guys so, so much.
if you joined in and watched or donated or anything.
Thank you, thank you.
And now I have to play all of MGS4 in one go with Johnny.
It's been a little crazy with the Charity Stream Emotion
Expo.
Hope you can relax.
Relax with this stream if Johnny lets you.
Yeah, I just literally, like, 30 minutes ago got out of two
back-to-back meet-and-greets.
So, I felt so bad.
There was, like, I couldn't.
there was more people waiting and I I couldn't they were
like you should go eat me though and I was like but but but
but but but but but but but but but but but they're like you
have a stream in 30 minutes and I was like but but but but I
always feel so bad
gonna take Johnny Akiba on a trip through MGS4 exactly hmm
yeah so if you were at the Moshi Expo and didn't get to see
me I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
But we're here.
We're chilling with Crime Scene Cleaner.
Forgot to add a goal to give Steiner a parachute or budget
for an extractor guide for the big jump.
Also, I hope Johnny is dumb as you hoped.
He's extremely stupid.
Thank you, Brian.
We'll consider the parachute.
Hey, I'm Intel currently making strawberry syrup because I'm
craving strawberry milk today.
You could just make strawberry syrup.
Oh my gosh.
Spooned Licker!
Happy birthday!
Yeah, he's pretty dumb.
Actually, I'm going to go check on him real, real quick, and
then we can get started, because I do have a concert tonight
at Moshi Expo, and maybe another little thing on somebody,
on maybe a Reaper's channel, perhaps.
Let me go check on him.
him real quick
a certain Reaper may haps perhaps maybe so today is
extremely busy very very very busy but that's a okay I want
to say that you are very cool Return to Half-Life 2 VOD.
Enjoy the VOD.
I also have to finish Half-Life 2.
Super cool.
Meeting you here at the official Moshi meet and greet, even
though I keep getting bashful.
See you later tonight for Rhythm Express.
See you!
Thank you!
So awesome meeting you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, it was really fun because with Moshi Expo, it's in the
Midwest.
It's in St. Louis.
misery so i have to uh um uh or not have to sorry i was able
to meet a bunch of new people but also see old people it was
really fun old ibun and ibu i've never met before hey me too
greetings from the uk thank you for keeping me company on
guard it was my birthday the other day and i got a voucher
for one free dinner with a ghost maid you know where i can
redeem oh so happy birthday first Thank you for the super
chai!
Happy birthday!
I'm not sure who is giving...
Where would you...
Who would be giving away?
How did you procure such a voucher?
But...
If you are sharing your food, I think a ghost maid may haunt
you sometime.
All you have to do is, uh...
All you have to do is just say, I offer this meal.
I mean, though, you know.
Or if you have, like, a little shrine set up for me in your
home, you just put it right, you just slap it right there.
Big old plate.
Let's continue crime scene cleaner.
Oh, yes, we just went to the art museum.
I forgot.
I'm excited for this.
this one this one looks insane um since i do have back to
work back to work of course oh wow it saved us right where
we were um since i do have uh uh more stuff tonight we'll
see how far we can get with uh cleaning and all this one's a
bit of a doozy though so it's kind of a
Well, yeah, kind of wow.
Let's just clean up this guy real quick.
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
Yep, uh-huh.
I need to clear the way first.
Oh, you?
The chances of getting killed by a dinosaur are low, but
never zero.
I don't even know where the entrance is.
But I think we're close to...
Oh, this is the maze room.
So...
Uh...
Okay.
This way, this way, this way.
Yeah, dino scene.
It's so awesome.
Element, hello!
Throw.
Nice.
Let's just, uh, find...
a place to put our bucket and start one room at a time, you
know?
Hey!
Oh.
Hefty balloon there.
Nice thumbnail.
Thank you!
Oh, they really want us to make use of all of our stuff now,
huh?
Like the pressure washer and everything.
Lead balloon, truly.
Well, for now, we'll just clean until I can't know more, and
then...
Oh.
You would think there would be a place for my bucket here,
no?
Something.
Why not?
Oh, my bad.
Oh.
Oh, I see, I see.
It's close by, maybe.
Wait, oh.
Huh?
I can't style bathroom.
Other side of the wall.
Is there another one?
Is that the only one in the whole place?
There's nothing else showing up on the...
I can't...
Okay, here's one.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Here's one, here's one, here's one.
This is much easier, I'd say.
Okay, we had a bit of a hack last time.
Where we had one...
Is this thing still broken?
Perfect.
One bucket that...
Held our detergent in it, right?
Let's do...
Yeah, the infinity detergent.
I think we'll definitely need that.
resistance.
So let's down the right at which tools get stained.
This might be a good one.
The stain one.
I can't remember how many our buckets can hold anymore.
Let's do the strength detergent as well.
Okay, only two at the moment.
That's fine.
Alright, and then let's get another bucket.
I mean, we could have two forever bucket forever detergent
buckets but um for now we'll just keep that one and this
will come with us we're doing one room actually what if we
like just start over there and kind of make our way back you
know i think that's fine too it shouldn't matter right all
right let's clean and detergent okay Yeah, only clean mobs
go into the soap bucket.
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wish we could turn on a light in here, though.
This stinking Roomba.
Can I trash can?
I don't remember what any of my...
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, I do have two...
Oh.
I do have two mobs.
Oh, it's dirty.
It's dirty.
Already?
Wait, how many...
This one was my soapy one.
Right?
Okay.
All right.
Causing a huge stinking mess for me.
Stupid.
The resistance doesn't...
I don't know if it makes much of a difference, huh?
Maybe it's just that much blood.
Doesn't seem so much...
like it when it's just a streak.
It's like when a dog rubs their butt on the floor.
Which they shouldn't be doing that.
If your dog does that, you need to take them to the butt.
Your dog should not be rubbing their butt on the floor.
Darno!
Congrats on the fundraiser.
There was a moment when 8008 was possible.
I tried to hit it, but then she was so amazing.
Oh, sorry.
Amazing with their concert.
Don't know that I just missed it.
Here's the for you in honor.
Of everyone's generosity for those.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I am so like...
Amazed by the fundraiser.
I think Steiner said that.
That was like their biggest...
Their biggest one this year.
So that's...
That's, that's, you know, like, that's a huge thing for, not
only just them, but, like, you know, for us, like, it's so
awesome.
Awesome community.
I know.
I love you guys so much.
Like, you know,
everybody's always just so awesome.
Yeah.
And, you know, don't feel like if you couldn't, if you
couldn't, donate or anything as well.
Don't feel like you're not included in that awesome bit.
You know, anybody just hanging around.
Oh, money.
Anybody just hanging around.
Anybody just you know, supporting in general.
Everybody's so awesome.
I think.
Minto, are we going to be seeing you at some anniversary
concert later tonight, perhaps?
Oh, I don't know.
I wonder.
I don't know.
Wouldn't that be so curious?
If you did, right?
Oh, I think it's the other side.
This room, you know what?
I'm glad we're getting this room done because it's
confusing.
Holy mackerel.
Am I not supposed to...
You got God with the Skellybone!
That's...
That dinosaur went on a killing spree that's sick who leaked
nobody oh wait maybe we take this oh defense is a good
offense collect the evidence oh sorry
metal i know right all right let's uh
wait this no i'm all i'm all backwards more war flies whoa
why
did they give you money what does that what does what will
money do in a battle royale like maybe you could be like
look i've got i've got a thousand bucks i'll bribe you i'll
bribe you i'll turn my frying pan into a dying pan oh
Plus two that way, everybody.
That was pretty good, wasn't it?
Plus two!
Yeah!
Is this dirty?
Is this, like, so dirty I can't use it anymore?
Streamer's so funny.
Thanks, it's my job.
Plus boo!
I don't know if it works if you ask for it.
Ah.
i was asking for that maybe what's this one say don't forget
to water plants and yourself
okay um all right cool
all right we got that guy out and uh okay here who is the
victor was
there i don't know what to do with this thing why is that
not an evidence
okay nothing here nothing here it absolutely works if you
ask for it i mean you guys listen so is this oh is this in
the right spot
he probably needs it back oh wait yeah yeah let's go grab it
oh spooky thank you wait thank you
oh it sounds like a skeleton trying to dance
I used the dying pan joke teaching before, so plus eight.
Ah, dang!
Thanks.
Okay, we'll just leave this here for now, I guess.
I have no idea where anything is supposed to go.
This maybe goes in here?
Oh, oh, oh, I see.
Hoko-kan.
There's many things.
things.
This is clean, right?
Yeah.
Parkour?
Oops.
Hard to see.
It's a parkour when you have a big old chair in your face.
My bad.
I think I needed to get that anyway, though.
Fortunately, most rooms are themed, so items are usually
easy to recognize.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean, though, I just wanted to say that some of the things
you said last night really touched me and for everything you
do and always being there for us also you're extra cute
today only today i'm just kidding
thank you gopaw thank you
this is supposed to go up here right yes why does why won't
it just please i can't parkour in these conditions
Please!
Oh my god.
No, no, no!
No!
Maybe try from the other side.
Oh, this way.
Oh.
Sorry, I can't... I can't see anything.
Oh, I'm not even on it.
Okay.
We got this.
Okay, hold on, watch this.
See, first try?
This...
Oh, it does...
Okay, wait, you can go through the pole.
I was gonna say, it's in my way.
Grab it?
Havaski!
Oh my god!
What goes here?
You!
We gotta win.
Firmly grasp it.
maybe we'll do this room
I mean we're in here after all might as well because we
finished that other room I think the gamer ghost she gets a
first try every try first try every time this one has no
suds on it That's such a dubs it up.
And we can clean the other guy while we're at it.
Oh, whoops, that's not what I meant to first.
Oh.
Alright.
First 50th try.
The best to ever do it, baby.
The best to ever do it.
Gosh, these rooms are wrecked.
Holy moly.
I hope you guys are having a good weekend so far though.
If you're not at a convention, I hope you're relaxed and
all.
Oh, hiya!
Oh, thank you so much.
Oh, oh.
A big painting must go here.
How fascinating.
Where did the...
Oh, the cushions go on there.
The chairs got it.
Spongebob time.
Oh
That is Oh
Yeah, oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh my god Nice.
Oh.
By over.
It's fine, actually.
I probably should go clean this off.
He looks a little silly right now because he's, like, you
know, missing half his face.
We can do this with the sponges, too, right?
Yeah, we can suds him up.
Suds him up, baby.
I also...
you're like half wished you know the you know the one uh
t-rex that goes
i wish it was underestimate the power of parkour he knows he
knows he gets it i kind of wish he said that
where does this one go then here okay don't move and
another cushion right here nice what's that I don't know I
stole something I have no idea what it is what oh oh I
thought that was to steal maybe I shouldn't take things from
the museum huh that seems a little wrong actually dinosaur
egg why would you have a battle royale in a museum by the
way kind of sound awesome but at the same time just seems a
little like disrespectful to the art no ambiance but the art
the art
where do you go oh you are a symbol oh what how did you get
all the way out here okay Because it's cool.
I'm not...
I'm not saying you guys are wrong.
Epic drum solo.
I wish I had that stain...
I wish that stains on my counter can be gone in one swipe of
a sponge.
I know.
That's why...
That's what makes these games so much better, you know.
Than like actually having to clean in real life.
Because things can get done so easily.
so it just makes it feel better like you're accomplishing
more in a short amount of time stop changing to that one
please you know I didn't upgrade the perk that allows you to
not have to worry about the stains but maybe I should have
night at them it was a night at the museum why does he
dual-wheeled like that because he's just so awesome is there
an exercise simulator yeah it's called uh oh dagger no
that's not what it's called it's called uh miku fitness
boxing ring fit for vtubers been a minute since i did the
ring fit though maybe i should i don't know
Actually...
I just had an idea!
You guys will never know...
Until you know.
Until I do it.
Isn't RingFit 4 VTubers?
Yeah, that's exactly why.
I mean, VTubers...
Well, they didn't start in 2020.
VTubers got more popular in 2020.
And RingFit happened.
Did RingFit happen?
What happened in 2020?
Something is blocking the way.
Oh, it must be whatever this is.
Oh, a painting.
She's thinking.
I have to keep some secrets.
It's my birthday tomorrow, I celebrated it early in Vienna
right now, waiting for my flight back in five hours and
luckily able to watch you tonight.
Galaxy, happy birthday, Vienna!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy happy birthday!
A secret makes a woman?
No, I have secrets you guys.
Exciting things though, exciting things that you will soon
know.
Where does this painting though go I will I wonder?
It won't move like this.
Still?
Oh.
Dang, Kovalski is crazy strong.
That's a... That's crazy.
Nice.
Janitor muscles, truly.
But yeah.
Mito, you were the first YouTuber that I watched.
Thanks!
Thanks for still watching.
I appreciate it.
Thanks, thanks, thanks.
It's always so crazy to me when people say that.
I don't know.
Some people will be like, oh, I...
And even today, even today, some people were like, I got
into...
I, I, you know, got more into Otage and idols because of
you.
And I'm like, me?
I...
I am that obsessed.
It rubs off on people.
Whoopsie!
Whoopsie, whoopsie.
Wait, where do these eggs go?
Maybe over here.
Good thing he's hefty.
What the heck is this thing?
Where do you go?
She's contagious.
Yeah.
I'm a contag- I'm patient zero sometimes.
I'm the contagion.
Luckily, some of these only need to be replaced.
Oh, what goes here?
But they don't have to be cleaned.
Be careful with the rolling things.
They're very easy to lose.
I know I'm worried about that.
I'm not going to lie.
I am worried about that.
Dirty.
Your passion is contagious.
I guess that's good.
You went to Summer Comic Kit.
here well you will we see you there for winter too i will or
rather i am planning on winter comic kit as well yes
actually yeah so there's some stuff happening
so I think if you are going to winter comic kit
it will be fun and not as hot not nearly as hot we'll wait
on that chair room because there's so many furniture is that
we don't have yet you know that oh buddy oh my god oh i
thought he was headless
not so not nearly as smelly yeah but the thing is is i
didn't think that not to that summer comicette was so smelly
anyway so it's you know could be worse right i've been to
for some real smelly places some real smelly conventions and
nearly headless how could you be nearly headless
yoink running away or stabbed in the back or both i like
when they rag doll after i take the thing that's holding
them down
yeah what how was the dino arm used right maybe oh here's
one maybe Maybe it was, like, his own weapon or something.
I could take it.
Okay.
Oops.
Uh, here?
Where will you go?
All the way up there.
Got it.
We're parkouring.
Here?
There.
Yes.
Awesome.
Oh, there's another one here.
Uh, okay.
Uh-huh.
Oh, so there needs to be a tiny table.
Oh, this one.
Okay, awesome.
What's that?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I just slipped on my chair.
This day was my birthday.
I'm glad I...
Glad I could make another trip around the sun.
Plus one day with you and all the other Aibus.
Topkins!
Yay, happy, happy birthday.
Happy birthday!
So many birthdays.
September.
Everybody had a fun time during...
Um...
During, uh...
New Year's, huh?
Oops.
Wait, I just realized.
Yeah, New Year's babies.
It was this one, right?
No, it wasn't.
Just kidding.
Where was it?
Where did it go?
Oh there it is.
Maybe it's the one...
You can never tell with art.
How am I to know it's the one on the ground like that?
New Year night celebrations.
It's kind of crazy how you can just like tell, you know,
like you could be like, uh, I was bored in September.
Oh man.
But more often than not, I don't want to think about.
What they're doing on New Year's.
I should clean it first.
Oh, you?
You?
No, not you?
I can't put it back like that.
Why not?
What's wrong with it?
What's it missing?
Stop shaming us September babies.
I'm not, I mean, well...
I'm not sure if October 1st is my birthday.
I call it my birthday.
The birth of being a ghost day.
It's like kind of a death day.
But it's my birthday.
But I'm not far behind is all I'm saying.
Ghost day.
Wow, it's already looking much nicer in here, huh?
Why was everybody touching this guy?
Quit it.
Basketball.
Please don't move those things.
Okay, good.
Yeah, we'll clean up all this.
And then move this guy back.
We can make this...
Oops.
We can make this main room nice spick and span.
Like nothing ever happened.
I mean, that's our job, huh?
Oops, wrong button.
He's a cute guy that deserves pets.
I concur.
You.
This is a really nice museum though.
This room sucks.
Oh my god.
Oh cute little snake.
Oh there's just trash everywhere.
Well it's not trash.
It's oh won't somebody think of the art.
Actually though.
Oh no there's are spots missing huh i was gonna say where
were these hidden but modern art you you can get a modern
modern cut on your foot modern disease with taking care of
with modern medicine right guys oh yeah modern pain
dang is this the Is this the elusive 1,000 times folded
katana of steel?
Whoa!
Somebody really messed up making their PV and J.
You're telling me.
Could it be Ken-sama no ken?
Oh, she looked kind of happy.
She was like, she like fell and was like, worth oh even here
oh oh both of them are bad it's okay we can sponge it
nice nice let's see how many move furniture back to its
place 14 out of 33 golly i'm guessing this needs to go here
right actually wait there's another gold one over here
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
Oh.
Nice.
Alright, here.
Okay.
What about you?
You're good.
Nice.
Here?
Oh.
You get a little ADHD in this game, I feel, when you have so
many...
You know what I mean?
Like...
comes before fixing so many things you have to do what oh
there's a little bit of blood on it and a little bit of
blood on the ground as well
that's some fresh swarming techniques you learned that while
working at sloppies oh yeah oh that's very strange bot again
i don't understand some i've said this before but sometimes
i don't understand the purpose of some bots you know what i
mean like why is your purpose to speak nonsense what are you
selling to me you know here not here
uh training some hidden model maybe oh maybe none of these
have frames do they always can see if it's over here nope
else activation phrases for sleeper agents in chat someone's
really like we just we just awoke like the new solid snake
oh my god new the ride in has been in this chat this entire
time and now he's awake oh let's go let's go clean our stuff
i wish though the
wasn't over here that I could find at least, you know.
Jack is back, baby.
Now he's awake.
Yep.
It worked on me.
I'm collecting went on an oil, to work on an oil rig right
now.
No!
Activation phrase heard, deploying tactical minkey.
No, that's not until phase two.
That's not until phase two.
Oh, here's one of the paintings from over here it's right
here back on the wall now why didn't they take it and why
did they bring it all the way over here for which purpose
these guys what
is my purpose to watch Minto stream.
Your purpose is to watch stream and laugh in chat at joke.
Watch this.
Thank you.
Whoa.
Alright, we're not going upstairs yet.
We're sticking downstairs for now.
You might be like, Minky, you missed a spot.
Don't worry.
I'll get back to it eventually.
I'm, again, little little all over the place with this game
like this spot probably someone has been tearing their hair
out like please please just get this spot i forgot our eyes
and nader initializing process of purification there you go
i just laugh watch me to stream yes good good chat is
balding chat is malding wait isn't that mean you're so mad
that become bald?
It's like, yes.
You are balding.
Due to malding.
Yeah.
I'm sorry to make you mad.
So mad that you become bald.
I really hope that doesn't ever happen to anyone.
It just sounds so sad that you become so angry.
You go bald.
It just sounds so sad.
Do I have to put that back?
Oh, yes, I do.
Oh, you're gross.
My hair.
Minto bald stream win.
Now, why do we need this?
As a bald man, I'm not upset.
I've become happier by becoming bald.
Let's go!
Look at all that.
Minito makes me so happy, I become unbald.
I'm not saying that being bald is a bad thing, by the way,
guys.
You know?
Oh, here's one, here's one.
Anything in here?
Okay, awesome.
You would think that they would, like, turn on the lights
for me, though.
Work.
Get rid of trash.
What are you talking about?
There's so much trash.
There's another guy in here.
I can't pick up anything with a full bag Bald is beautiful
Bald is beautiful Bald is beautiful If you are bald, you are
beautiful And I mean that from my heart Bald is beautiful
And you are beautiful
From the very start.
What?
Whoa, what is this room?
We haven't...
Ah!
Winchester Mansion.
We haven't been in here yet.
Oh!
More Lulu suicide.
Better luck next life.
Flip me.
Wink!
It wasn't really that funny to the almighty VIPs.
Oh my gosh.
Wink, wank.
Better next one.
Wait.
I already messed it up.
Better luck next life.
Wait, can I?
Okay, good.
Good one.
This is why I'm not a killer.
This is why I'm not a killer, you guys.
Maybe I should bring my third one.
bucket with me I don't know I so this place is so ginormous
I feel lost wait which one did I just have out oh wait I got
to clean this guy too
that's what a killer would say though though no no
Let's call it a draw.
All right, let's grab this guy.
We got some more dinosaur fossil parts.
The most convincing defense.
I have nothing to hide.
Don't shake your head.
What do you mean?
You think I have nothing?
You think I have something to hide?
Sayonara, brave samurai.
You're so brave.
That was so brave of you to say that.
Kovalsky well the red hair truly pops this is I think a
museum like this would be so cool though like it's kind of
silly but I think like you know going to it and being like
whoa I think it'd be pretty fun where where where huh says
it's I don't know where.
Oh.
Right there.
Like, this would be a really cool place to be at.
Like, I love when...
When museums and stuff have themed rooms like this, and
they're all over.
And it's pretty neat.
It's pretty neat.
I'm guessing it goes, like, here.
Oh, there.
There?
Oh.
there.
Whoa.
What's up here?
Oh my god!
Goink.
Oh there's even a body in here?
Death everywhere.
What is actually kind of genius?
If I were in one of these things I might like okay spoilers
for saw one I would I think I would like find someone else
that died and then I would hide in their blood like really
cover myself you know and then wait for everybody else to
kill each other and then I'd be like I've been alive the
whole time
yes that's what I would do and it would be so epic saw ew it
looks like somebody peed in the toilet because everything is
yellow I don't take credit for that one though I'd give that
to jigsaw saw 2000 whatever came out I did saw it come out.
What a funny series.
John Jigsaw.
2004.
Wow.
That's wait, that's a really long time ago, isn't it?
Wait, is this blood?
Oh, it is, yeah.
All right, then you too, you have some blood on you also.
I thought it was a design choice.
How foolish of me to think That they would want anything
other than yellow First things first Gotta scrub scrub scrub
What are you talking about?
Oh there's tiny bit right down there That's what Oh my gosh
Thank you Scrub scrub scrub scrub Crazy to say 2004 was a
long time ago I know right It's like Ouch Maybe don't
mention that.
There was a globe somewhere, right?
And this guy goes... Oh, there's like a gamer chair
somewhere.
Okay, wait, I missed where this guy goes.
You guys see?
There's also blood there.
I don't see.
Oh, up the ladder probably.
You guys are right.
There it is.
Thank you, thank you.
there was a globe somewhere there it is thank
you guys so awesome I to ponder the ore about my dinner
table when
do I unlock the perk that I don't break any glass huh huh do
you think the egg goes here the triplets are back to get it
does oh here's chair to the yellow room the lady in the
yellow wallpaper would would hate this room yellow to yellow
oh my gosh yeah sometimes uh i'll be recording stuff in like
a green screen and say like vr chat or something you know um
and obviously when i'm in vr chat in vr uh it's like you
know that's all i can see so very often
um like i'll be recording in vr chat in the green screen
world and then when i leave my vision is like pink so that
room remind like makes me think if you were to stay in that
room for so long and then you left what would the world
somebody who knows colors what would the world look like
afterwards
yes yes it's pink it's pink nice and then we had another
person and another oh you're all dirty though so the Ace
Combat 8 live action prequel is going to be 4 episodes each
episode is 8 to 11 minutes long for each episode is going to
be on IGN YouTube channel Next week.
15th, 17th, 23rd, 29th.
Project Ace will be super...
Yeah!
I watched the trailer for...
I actually, somebody came to my meet and greet today and
talk about Ace Combat.
And just like how much they're putting into, you know, the
series to help.
You know, what I said was like...
That I'm only a newer Ace Combat fan.
I'm a newer Ace Combat fan, but they're doing so much.
It's like so awesome, you know, and it just feels like
they're really...
Trying to breathe some life into the franchise.
It's so cool.
As long as you're having fun.
Yeah, I mean...
I mean, you could even say I'm a relatively...
I mean, compared to some people, I'm a newer Metal Gear fan.
So, it's all kind of, you know.
It is just what it is, but...
Yeah.
Wow, this is clean and crazy.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I can move up to 99% of harmful particles from here.
I've got a ton of stuff.
Why does it sound like me?
What do you mean?
What do you mean, imposter?
It's not.
It wasn't you.
It was someone else.
Oh, and there's more people that like Ace Combat out there.
Uh-oh.
Oh, I almost knocked it over.
Crime scene cleaners are oftentimes small businesses.
businesses please do messy crimes oh oops this one support
messy crimes and those that that clean them up this is a
small room we could do this one oh what's in here cereal and
milk wait what's this oh geez louise lady
Is that the weapon they gave her?
That's messed up.
I feel...
Oh, there was a...
Wait, no.
Oh my gosh, wait.
This one's so cute.
It's like a little Sadako dog.
Oh, he's like the ring.
That's cute.
And this one is like...
Here's Johnny!
Wait, I'm gonna go...
I don't hear my cat.
Hold on.
Let me go check up on him.
One second.
If the eye has prolonged exposure to certain wavelengths,
colors of light, the world will be tinge opposite colors as
it takes the rest of the colors.
I can remove up to 99% of harmful particles from here.
He's sleeping in bed.
I got an...
I'm trying to...
scoot my chair forward okay there we go I got a new chair
that has like an actual backrest on it so I've been trying
to use it you know oh oh that was a piece of pottery oh I
thought it was dirty it showed red so
well give me a second actually I'll put you oh where are you
in this room because We'll be going in here next.
Do you like the new chair?
I like it.
It's just different so far.
But I do like it.
What is this one?
Is this fight club?
Spider-Man duck!
Oh.
That'd be cool!
Thank you so much for the fight.
I'm gifted.
Soap one is Fight Club.
Okay, that's what I thought.
The mirror one I don't get.
What is the mirror one, you guys?
What is the mirror one?
This one.
Actually, I don't understand this one either.
School days?
School days, ducks?
Is this just my imagination, or am I seeing a lot of ducks
lately?
Fox one was seven even.
Oh, seven.
Oh!
I don't know.
I don't know that one, actually.
Oh, wait.
Where did this come from?
What?
Okay, I'm going to put this here.
Because that's a tough...
That one I almost lost.
It looks so similar to the floor, you know?
That almost lost it.
Let's do this chair.
It's good.
What's it about?
Can I please?
We're fine, we're fine.
Oh.
There we go.
How many more do I have in here?
Two?
Two left?
Okay.
Serial killer based off the seven deadly sins.
Oh, cool!
Wait, that does sound like that.
good i think maybe taxi driver are you talking to me oh this
guy you talking to me you talking to me when they first
showed the ace combat live action trailer i was shocked
because suddenly project ace got unlimited right it was
crazy well
hey we love to see it they seem very passionate about
everything so oh oh dang it all right that should be
everything in this room oh just kidding and then I think I
saw some over here or something yeah just a few little
droplets let's grab this guy come on Get you to the truck.
Seven stars Brad Pitt, Morgan Freeman, they play police
detectives who hunt a serial killer whose victims are chosen
based on the representation of the seven deadly sins.
I see.
So close.
Oh, we still got it, baby.
And let's grab the lady in here.
Cleaning comes before fixing.
What else needs to be cleaned?
It's clean!
Fine.
Oh.
I'm ready for more work.
Seven is older than most YouTubers.
That's a horrifying thought.
Actually, well, I don't even know how old it is.
Brad Pitt and Morgan Freeman.
I mean, that could be any era.
Did I not suds this one?
Maybe?
1995.
Released in 95.
Old.
Older than FF7.
Wait, when did Final Fantasy VII come out?
95 is age.
95 is an old.
me though okay it's not old i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding
who am i i don't know time i'm a ghost oh nice we got this
whole room or almost mine misplaced okay so egypt room
somewhere we'll place you here oops my bad there's nothing
to do We got to clean up this lady.
30.
Oh, evidence.
30 is the new 19.
Wait, I'm 19.
Someone was having their Egypt phase.
That's so relatable.
Oh, cool.
Modern art painted with blood.
Rules.
The last man alive wins.
Only one winner claims the prize.
You can't surrender.
You can't bring anything from the outside you can always
anything found in the building if you find the supply box
you can use its contents you will be led to different
starting locations the game starts on a signal you can't
leave the building you can't enter the VIP zone any rule
breach results in death good luck I think I've seen this
film before squid games I've played these games before.
Hmm, I wonder if we should take care of this room now.
Doesn't seem so bad, honestly.
Just a little bit of blood.
I was thinking hunger games.
Hunger games.
Yeah.
The original squid game.
Grandpa.
The day the music survived.
Oh my god.
I'll skew.
Oh, man.
I don't know about that one, buddy.
Oh.
It was okay.
Wait, is this an item, too?
Ah, ah, what is that?
Oh, my gosh.
There's...
Okay, this goes with this thing over here.
We'll put them right here.
You, you.
You guys are kind of similar.
That was not his best, you guys.
It was not his best.
Appeals here.
I love going to a modern art museum and getting to the rug
room.
You know?
Where?
It just looks like a mall.
It's really exciting.
Textiles.
No, no.
Oh, no.
Wait, how do I get that one up there?
Wait, there's a cassette up there!
How do I get it?
Jumping puzzle.
Oh, there's a thing here!
Good to know.
Actually, oh, I did that.
I was like, wait, the painting!
I threw the painting over the balcony, but I was like
thinking, oh wait, the painting might actually be...
The area might be up here.
Not bad.
Oh, it changed colors.
You see that?
Ooh.
Yellow.
Orange.
Blue.
It was like blue, yellow.
How do I...
Okay, hold on.
These are animals.
Okay, you can go downstairs.
Where did that go, actually?
Okay.
Oh, I forgot to, I got, I took the body from this guy and I
forgot to put it back.
Oh, there's so much stuff, isn't there?
Holy moly.
If the time comes, I hope you will spare me.
Stop, why does he think?
Oh, I see, I see.
I see, for these, for these funky looking ones, it's in
here.
Over here.
You?
No.
Yay!
So, okay, good.
crazy for one guy to clean this all in one night it's it
would yeah i'm not paid enough for this i think actually
like you can joke about that but i legitimately don't think
we're getting paid enough for this mint you clean crime
scenes want to clean up a date with me ryan well ryan um
what is a clean What is a cleaning date involved?
Because that's kind of like, as a maid, like it's kind of,
you know...
It comes with the territory.
It's not really my idea of a date, I'd say.
Don't mix business and pleasure.
Exactly, exactly.
Yeah.
Oh.
thinking man I also wonder what some people have in their
heads okay so a lot of statues go in here it's oh wait also
maybe that Egyptian one you go in stop staring at me turn
around now the Pharaoh's curse won't reach me nice let's
keep cleaning this area we're almost done here Oops.
Hmm.
Maybe that's okay.
Ah, ah.
Oh, this is the one I dropped on the floor.
That I shouldn't have.
I can't see anything.
Just going off of sheer will.
Instinct.
Nice.
Queen Nefertiti.
I'm the opposite.
Nefertiti?
I'm a queen.
Queen always TD.
Am I right, boys?
Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Um, let's bring Osmo Man over to the rug room.
We'll do that one next.
Okay.
I don't like that they gave him feelings.
I don't understand.
Can you elaborate?
I'll explain when you're older, Ibu.
Some things are just a little too mature for you right now.
That's okay, Ibu.
You'll get it when you're older.
I think this room... Oh, I was gonna say I think this room
is good, but...
It is not... Oh wait.
Now is it good?
Seems good to me.
Besides that thing up, this looks like a mecha chameleon
room.
I don't know why.
Hmm.
Dewey age?
Oh my gosh.
Why is there so much parkour in this freaking level?
Oh, come on, please.
I'm a genius.
Can I just grab it?
Whoa!
Secret.
Oh, the mother load!
Yeah!
How is this going to help you survive in a battle royale?
Money, money, money, baby.
Whoa.
Oh, neat.
What the heck are these?
The Nubis life-size statue.
Milk.
Yeah, I guess you could find it and then hide, right?
Everyone else was too stupid.
But me, I was a genius.
And I knew how to find it.
But then you leave the puzzle.
Like, I guess you could close it after you do it.
jump right i'm gonna say though you kind of leave the puzzle
open if you death by paper cuts you leave the the puzzle
open if you cleaning is my passion if you don't shut the
cassette tapes purification complete guy
i was also thinking the milk was unrefrigerated and it
concerned me but you know what i think everybody here is a
is a savage anyway so they would drink they would Ugh, milk
that is not refrigerated.
I'm ready for more work.
Like, what is going on here?
La la la la, cleaning up the rooms.
Oh, bunnies!
Cleaning up after ourselves.
No.
There is a VIP event planned for tomorrow.
Count it as your day off.
No need to turn anything off.
Text will take care of everything.
We will see each other on Monday.
Have a good rest till then.
Manager.
Never say no to a paid day off.
He like saved them.
He like saved the person, you know, so that they wouldn't,
you know, that they wouldn't die from being in here.
I guess that's kind of nice.
Nobody checked the drawers.
He saved him.
He saved us.
Save that guy.
Oop.
Yoink.
That scared me.
I thought it was a person.
Oh, golly.
Okay, so here's the...
There also is a door over here?
Oh.
Where there...
Oh, nice.
Whoever got this room...
Got lucky.
Well, not quite.
Someone didn't get along with the rest of the band.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, yeah, yeah.
That scared me.
wow this place is really cleaning up well though huh okay we
can take this one upstairs because we know uh around here
just a little little big for some of these doorways okay
yeah it's looking much better okay come on come on buddy all
righty let's see if i were a painting taken from the walls
i'd be here okay we gotta clean up first what the heck what
a psycho they've made like a frame of blood
don't think about falling again i'm falling for you like
look how nice this looks i mean our our guy isn't complete
even a little bit, but...
Alright, I am gonna finish this.
I think it'll be time to bring our buckets elsewhere.
Finally.
I'm sure that's been driving some people crazy.
Please don't flame me in the comments.
I will cry.
Very nice.
And then this was the VIP room.
I believe.
Yes.
Who was the winner?
Nobody.
Good game.
Good game team.
We love a rigged game, don't we guys?
Who wins?
The house.
The house always wins.
Okay, and we'll scrub a scrub a scrub of this one.
I think, uh, what's his name?
Uh, our, our little Ozinator.
Oh, wait.
Here's a painting, too.
Where does this go?
In here?
Oh, nice.
Um, I think his reach reached up here, maybe.
The T-Rex always wins.
Ain't that a kick in the head?
The room wasn't Completely black.
I kissed her and she kissed back.
Like a fella said, Ain't that a hole in the bow?
Or something.
My head keeps spinning.
I go to bed.
I keep grinning.
And there's just the beginning.
My life is gonna be beautiful.
Oh wait.
Let's go to the bandroom first.
actually gonna be beautiful I haven't sung that since Romito
with love so long ago huh oh good times good times I have a
question if I wash my things I it's been it's maybe a little
late into the game for me to be asking this but if I wash my
Things get messy.
They have soap on them.
But they get messy and I wash the soap.
Well, they have soap on them.
They have blood on them.
I have to wash it.
Anyway, will the soap come off?
That's all I'm trying to ask.
Feels like it, but it was less than a year ago.
I know it was literally this year.
Oh, nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
Alright.
Beats me.
Please.
Um.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Holy cow.
We're fine.
Everything is good.
Nice.
Okay, and then this guy right here.
I don't know how you even...
Move you.
Okay.
Love the sound.
I know it's really satisfying, isn't it?
Okay.
We need a couple more things.
What's this?
Steel?
I have no idea what that was, but I took it.
Yeah.
A couple more.
Three more things in here.
That's fine.
Oh, here's one.
Here's one.
There we go.
All right.
And there.
Oh, this might be the room that I was trying to find
earlier.
Spooky.
Okay, and this was the door I was trying to open earlier.
I am really half expecting one of these mannequins to, like,
I turn around and she's in a different spot.
Beautiful, beautiful.
Then where shall we go next?
Um...
Oh,
here's a...
Here's a gold room chair.
That should be the last one in here.
I think.
Oh.
Weeping angel.
Ooh.
Oh!
Really!
Thank you so much for the pink!
If you put your dirty mop into a bucket with soap it'll
clean and reapply the soap back on say nothing about the
mannequins they are always watching thank you for the you
might have been trying to explain that to me earlier and i
just wasn't looking i'm so sorry thank you so much though
thank you thank you thank you um awesome mannequins are only
slightly less scary than the clowns yeah exactly there you
go wait i think i don't think clowns are that scary actually
i think mannequins are scarier than clowns that's my that's
my opinion
yay oh man we're getting this you guys hour and a half in
holy moly oh yeah it does say mop it does say moppy us or
soapy this one is not soapy anyone
Okay, you'll go, um, I guess we'll go into this room.
Initializing process of purification, refreshing the air.
I'd say is good time for this.
Take it.
And then there's this guy here, too.
Wait, not the axe.
I'm just going to pressure wash it real quick.
Okay.
Easy peasy.
Lemon squeezy.
Getting to spend my birthday on the Minto stream.
Ellie, happy birthday!
Or L, happy birthday!
Happy happy birthday!
Thank you so much for 27 bucks!
It was great talking with you at the meet and greet!
Can't wait for the concert later.
Yes!
Thank you for coming to see me.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
This is also something that goes somewhere.
No clue where.
In here?
No, it's not the same color.
Unless?
No.
Okay, I thought that might be blood, but...
Oh, it goes here!
Oh, oops.
I love the art, you guys.
Okay, awesome, awesome, awesome.
Let's take this chair.
And...
It might be easiest to go upstairs with it.
Uh...
Like so.
Yeah!
Okay, so now there's just one more.
Okay.
right here.
And I'm gonna go first things first.
Scrub, scrub, scrub.
Yep, I know.
I know.
The first thing is wrong.
Something is blocking the way.
It's me.
I'm blocking the way.
Alright, we'll grab, we'll get this area first, right?
We're not too far from the bucket, I suppose.
I wonder if the other bucket cleaning area is like down
below us, though.
So if Work, work, work, work.
So true.
That's literally what I'm doing.
I am work, work, working, baby.
Dark, good thing is so much for the fine.
Good thing.
Oh, raiders!
I didn't see who raided.
Granny?
Rosary!
Hello!
Thank you for raiding!
Hello, guys.
We're cleaning up this very, um...
a lot of spaghetti was being made here and it was a crazy
crazy time because you know chefs are not very not known to
be very cleanly don't you hate it when things that should be
dead and totally wait what totally unnoticed keep appearing
and yapping and yapping and yapping anyway good luck with
the mannequins ghost girl
What do you mean by that?
Okay, born, thank you, donkey, thank you, boy, thank you.
I think I need to replace this.
Oh,
there's another thing missing?
No, and there's candy on the couch.
Am I not...
I am... am I not free to yapp?
In fact, I would say that's all ghosts do.
Give them a spirit...
Something or other?
Or spirit box and...
A ghost will yapp.
Give a ghost a spirit box and they'll yapp for...
A lifetime or...
Or something.
I don't know.
Is it not my dead given right?
To yapp?
Am I being silenced?
Oh, there were stairs here the entire time, you guys.
Oh, no.
There were stairs here the entire time.
I'm ready for you to shut up.
If I'm being silenced, no one can speak.
Summoning!
Silence, no Jutsu!
Wow.
Ah.
There's money everywhere.
Did anyone make it out alive?
Or...
You know.
Did anyone make it?
There's just cash everywhere.
Give me all the yaps you got.
You guys, will you guys be...
Yes, here it is.
Will you guys be good boys and girls?
Wait, there's this chair that needs... Oh, shoot.
Oh, shoot.
I can remove up to 99% of harmful particles from here.
Did I hear a guitar?
Okay, we gotta go get our...
Shoot.
Don't, don't, don't, don't break.
Don't break.
We gotta go get our...
Our buckets.
Oh, sorry.
Wait, did I just move that?
No, take it.
Okay.
The guitar is in there.
Yeah.
Okay, I'll bring you guys back.
I'll bring you guys back.
Where would you go?
There you are.
Pop, a smurf.
Thank you so much for the pink.
to say thanks for one year as a mostly lurk boo so proud of
all you've accomplished i can't wait to see what the future
holds thank you so much thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you all right let's go get our buckets wait oh did
i did i move that no we're fine
Not for nothing, but wow, look at all these hammers.
And that suspiciously nail-shaped eyeball.
How suspicious.
How intriguing.
You know, I always forget that I have a third bucket even.
I should probably start utilizing that.
Oh, you.
You.
I should start utilizing the third bucket.
J-B, thank you.
Ask if you can say Scar's famous line from the Lion King
when you...
you throw Steiner out of the plane, he'll be expecting long
live the king, but you hit him with, I've always wanted a
brother.
The famous line, the famous line known from it, known by one
and all.
Scar's famous line.
I've always wanted a brother.
Oh, there's the guitar.
He must have had some other plans, then, just to participate
in their game.
Is this, like, the VIP guy?
The guy that owned it all?
This is the guy that set it up?
What?
Oh, my God.
No way.
The people that I brought in to do my death game?
No, they killed me?
What do you mean?
The people that signed up to play a death game are all
crazy.
They're all...
They're they're all bloodthirsty criminals?
No way!
How could... how could this happen to me?
That's so crazy.
Choo, thank you!
Nya-ya!
Yeah, yeah.
I just realized there's so much stuff on the floor that
could break, so I'm just gonna trash it anyway.
Oh, it won't let me.
Wait, it won't let me.
Oh, that's evil.
Fine, I'll sponge it all.
Congrats on the charity stream!
I was glad to be able to donate.
I was in a really dark place a few years ago, but VTuber's
like, you helped me through it.
Oh, bookworms!
I'm glad I'm so happy you're doing better.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glappy.
I'm happy.
I'm grateful and happy that you donated as well.
Thank you.
Membership keeps killing our timing.
It is, it is.
Sorry.
There's no way for me to turn off the... I've looked into
it.
There's quite truly no way for me to turn off the
membership.
Like...
What's it called?
Oh, I guess you'd call it a...
Oh, that's evil.
Gap that it does.
Glappy.
That guy must have really spoiled their fun.
There's so much money here.
Aw, man.
We were having fun.
We were...
We were just killing people.
It was just innocent death fun why would you why would you
put a stop to our fun
glappy rock and roll
okay this is awesome
get rid of all the trash let's go there's so much cash on
the ground holy moly Let's take this back home, I guess.
Hooray, hooray, hooray.
I feel like after this room, it's not much left, maybe.
Nice.
Like, we've moved most of the furniture.
Dispose of garbage bags.
Wipe the blood.
Does that include over here?
Well, there's like this area that I did not do yet.
Oh!
Oh, the central exhibition is 100%!
Let's go!
Okay.
Check your email box for an email from Ryan.
You do know all my emails go to my manager, right?
Oh, I have Oh Um
Oh That might be a shock
Let's see Where does this guy go?
Oh there Right there right there Nice
Yeah guys You know what actually like Phoebe especially but
we've been you know trying to get Steiner set up with
somebody you know I but Phoebe especially has been really
like she's been really adamant about about helping Steiner
find a girlfriend
so Ryan It can be you!
This is exactly what we were...
We've been looking...
This is perfect!
9% of harmful particles...
Thank you!
Yeah, if anybody's single looking to mingle...
Don't use my email, but you know, you can email Stun.
You can email me, pick me.
All you, baby.
All you.
where oh oh okay hold on more candy hidden candy okay hold
on let's actually use these bad boys this should be cozy
place to watch people fight for their lives i was about to
say that should be all the blood is that really all the
blood oh wow we okay guys we're so close we're so close
But I'm still missing a chair.
For this room.
Have you guys seen it?
I feel like Dora the Explorer.
Aye, boo.
Have you seen the missing chair?
I think I did everything up here.
Yeah.
Blue is close.
Where did you see the chair?
Oh.
There!
Did you see where that feather went?
Oh yes, it was in here.
Why do you know where it goes?
This guy?
How do you know my name is Aibu?
Lucky guess.
That's a head.
And a bust.
And a wheel.
Oh my gosh.
Right outside.
Oh really?
Ah, I see, I see.
Thank you.
Oh, and there's the hand that I needed, one of them at
least.
He blended right in.
Here?
Okay.
Very good.
Maybe...
I haven't been in here in a while.
We've cleaned up much more now.
There's also, like, a painting that...
Seemed to be out of place.
I haven't...
Shoot.
Oh.
Oh!
The chair!
I found it!
Check the hoops!
Yeah!
Thank you!
It looked like it could have been part of the exhibit, so I
didn't even think.
Modern art is truly something else.
Oh, yes.
All right.
Um...
exhibits there's another one in here is there I suppose
maybe back here
is this toaster part of this one what is that even for wait
this likes it oh it must reveal wait secret secret this will
open wait What color does it need to be?
How should I know?
How would I know?
I thought maybe this one is blue, so maybe blue like the
toaster.
Uh...
Oh, secret, secret, secret!
I had to use a guide for this one.
Security room had colored screens.
Does it now?
Okay.
Thank you.
I'm lost again.
I am once again looking for the exit.
Pink static mint Oh pink and green and orange and blue Wait
pink Okay pink static Green orange blue Static Pink static
Green orange blue static Static was the last one right?
Yeah Pink and green and blue We'll start a legend anew
I'm lost again.
Okay.
And mint.
Wait.
Which word?
Where's the static?
Wait, huh?
Wait, but they're all...
not in the same oh orange oh sorry blue static or static
blue uh
top right needs to be green i think top right is static pink
static mint orange blue static yeah but they're not in the
same of like three and three.
And this is definitely not three and three.
Check the ceiling.
The ceiling?
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Maybe, um, this one, and then orange here, and then blue,
oh, blue here, and then static.
Easy peasy.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
With this, katana, I will be known as the greatest white
Japanese person ever.
Oh my
god, it's Metal Gear Rising!
just happened.
Do I have to clean this up?
Oh!
Economy of pain.
Thank you.
I'm gonna go destroy the other mannequins.
I'm gonna go destroy the rest of them.
It didn't seem to add to our cleaning total, so I think
we're good.
There was one up here.
It's gone!
Oh!
What about the one over here?
Oh my god!
They're actually gone!
Wait, that's kind of freaky, no!
Oh my god, I did kill them all!
Whoa!
We just... We sheathed our sword.
Did any of these go at the bar?
No.
Oh, shoot.
Modern Art Night.
Paint it with blood.
Yasuke Yuzuki.
Most kills.
$20,000.
Nick Knight.
Last Demand standing.
$40,000.
Naui Mikuri.
Find secret room.
Oh, this is like their bedding car.
Okay, ah, yeah.
This is what they bed.
Interesting.
Holy.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I missed the gifts.
Oh, hi, Johnny.
What's up?
Mr. Alsef, thank you so much for the 50 gifts.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you so much.
Come here.
Oh, sorry.
You want to sit in my lap?
You might have to actually come, come, come here.
Come this way.
Yeah.
And then jump up here.
yeah good boy jump up here jump up here there you go and
then jump up here there you go he's not a very good jumper
oh you're not you don't want to hang out oh there you go
yeah yeah yeah there you go get on that part first and then
you can get in my lap there you go good boy good boy anyone
noticed kensan last night sounded like old man patty from
twinkle dogs i was hearing it too hi johnny oh my goodness
oh he's on my face always look in my face hi there boy hello
oh he's in my lap hi dear johnny hello hello here you you
want to hang out for a bit you can just lay you can Lay
there.
Don't chew the cable, please.
Those are my headphones.
No.
Okay.
Yeah, he's very dog-coded.
Alright.
I guess you can put a price on human life.
Yeah, he just kind of, like, chills in my lap sometimes, and
we just...
We're just hanging out and watch TV or something, so...
Yeah, you could just lay right there.
Okay.
Alright, tables.
Like, this one goes here.
Chair goes here.
Table number two goes here.
Chair goes there.
On chair.
Goes here.
I can remove up to 99% of harmful particles from here.
Chair goes here.
Insert.
If it fits or sits.
Or something.
Oh, come on.
Stop biting that.
What's his favorite show he doesn't really watch i tried
putting on like cat tv for him and he would only stare at me
but honestly i think he's not a cat i think he's like very
strange he's more like a dog but also i've joked that i
think he's a reincarnation of the guy from nutty putty cave
because he he's kind of obsessed with like um what is that
oh it's just actual sugar with trying to get like underneath
things and crawling under things so often when he's like
when he's like trying to and he's they're really small
squeezed places like under my couch and under my bed he'll
be like he'll be I'll joke I'll be like oh this is just like
the cave ever fear that you summon the curse of ibs on a pet
after you've cleaned after the name johnny no i think he's
okay i think he's fine i mean to pledge he finally arrived
yesterday mr mr lrb thank you so much for waiting and thank
you for ordering it thank you so much i'm so happy it
arrived hopefully she does not cause too much trouble
yeah he'll like really it's really funny because he like
kind of does funny poses to get into the hold on let me move
my mic a little bit more to get into like the the um this
the little crevices that he likes to investigate um he makes
like a funny frog pose to get in there
have you bought him a cat tunnel i did i did i'm waiting on
it to come though okay we're missing some chairs uh-huh
there's nothing to do here oh this is also i'm surprised we
don't have to pick up any of these it says like the game is
ended someone's gonna be like the game now what's that
what's the game we have this painting here as well i do not
know where this goes though uh-huh oh Is that okay?
Is that alright?
Was that a yawn?
That was a dramatic yawn if so.
Is it okay?
The game you lost.
You just lost the game.
I'm guessing this goes upstairs or something.
I don't know.
Maybe.
I can't believe all the mannequins disappeared.
That's kind of insane.
This game is awesome.
I don't know.
I don't think it's one of these, but it could be.
It is, it is, I missed this one.
Oh, wait, uh.
Now you can go back to being admired.
Yeah!
If one provides Fumominto with regular sacra, or gifts, she
stays behaved.
Yes.
Gifts.
All right.
um we have to collect evidence in here we're missing one and
then we got to move the furniture back to place those are a
couple wait but i thought oh here's a chair i thought it was
only two chairs these two chairs though what else needs to
be oh there's another one over here oh i see i see okay
that's fine didn't break we're all all as well Okay, so
we're missing a chair.
We're missing an evidence.
What?
If I were an evidence, what would I be?
Uh...
Oh, here's a chair.
Chair, where?
Chair, here, go.
Okay, evidence, evidence.
Oh, I see it down here.
Nope, that's cash.
Cash.
Err.
Cash money.
Oh!
Are you okay?
Oh, you not feeling so well?
I'm ready for more work.
You can go, you can go.
You're okay.
You might have a hairball.
It's right there.
Wait, they passed it?
It's on a table.
Oh!
Sorry, guys.
Are you okay?
You can come back if you feel better.
Clark.
CEO.
Busy.
Sorry, he's like not throwing up.
He's kind of being like, you know.
Busy tonight.
Text me if anything happens.
Clark.
Then I will keep you updated.
Crime coin is suddenly rising in value.
Crime coin.
Should we buy?
I'm telling you, it's going to skyrocket soon.
Boss, hello, can I buy it?
Boss, it's urgent.
Answer, please!
It has probably crashed by now.
Ooh, the owner's not the crime coin.
You coming back?
Come back up here.
Set my lap again.
Come here.
You're okay.
He's not a very good jumper, so I have to, like, kind of
ease him.
Yeah.
right you're a silly guy who doesn't know how to jump very
well okay there you go you're fine there's nothing to do
here his name's not billy his name is johnny does he purr a
lot he does he purrs a ton his purr box is like crazy he's
not good at jumping because he's stupid or because he's fat
He's not fat at all.
Yeah, you're not fat.
I think he's just kind of silly.
He, uh...
When he was a kitten, he had a bad infection.
And it's kind of, like, messed him up a little bit.
Okay, we gotta move some furniture back here.
Alright, what are we missing?
Oh.
Oh!
I don't think I grabbed these before.
Nice.
Okay.
Um...
and find a misplaced exhibit.
Yeah.
Little Johnny.
Move some furniture.
Don't throw up on me, please.
You want to go drink some water?
Are you okay?
Yulking?
He's acting fine otherwise.
No, don't get on my desk, please.
you okay you want to just keep laying here you you okay
you're still laying on my legs okay we're still trying to
find this right johnny right everybody i wonder if like yeah
i think the missing exhibit is that toe i was thinking that
i don't know what else could be missing in terms of
are you good on time?
Let me double check.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I think this will be our only room today, though,
unfortunately, but we'll finish up the game next week.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh, but also this guy.
And this one, too.
Where could they be?
Ah.
This place is ginormous.
It's so hard to find anything.
So we're looking for a bust head.
Like this guy.
Oh, this guy's head.
That bust.
And then this circly thing.
Under there.
Underwear.
Oh my god.
You just baited me to say underwear.
Didn't you?
Oh no.
No.
Got a hunt for any areas with misplaced exhibits.
So this one.
This one has a misplaced exhibit.
For sure.
But it's...
That's one.
Alright.
Now it has none.
But there's still furniture that needs to be moved back.
And I think there's three of them.
One of them is definitely the toe.
Oh.
Yoink.
dark room checked the hoops okay thank you
oh my gosh thank you thank you thank you okay so the
misplaced ones okay i get it misplaced has to be back where
you belong okay okay okay now we're still looking for
the furniture here
some of these rooms are like hard to read you know what i
mean like they say like the the the central exhibition this
see this is not the central exhibition this is the north
exhibition so it's kind of like confusing you know so
somewhere in this room things need to go back in there or
something.
It's not the basketballs, right?
No.
I'm not seeing anything.
That's the issue.
I also adopted a cat recently.
I'm wondering if Johnny was nervous when he first arrived at
your place.
My cat was very anxious and always hid under the bed.
Now she's much more relaxed.
Oh, a charm skate!
Oh, congrats on adopting another kitty.
I am no he was totally fine within like 30 minutes he was
laying in my lap he was totally okay the shelter says that
he has a funny confidence that many cats don't have she also
cleared the colored rooms if so I think the remaining items
should be upstairs and in the cantina.
Cantina.
Um, this room is complete.
This room is complete.
Complete.
Let's go upstairs.
Up for passage.
Cafeteria is complete.
main room might have some crooked paintings oh that's true
but we're still missing this dino's toe yeah crooked
paintings would make sense now wouldn't it and that's kind
of something I haven't been looking at
wait a second this doesn't belong here does it no this
belongs over here
okay that's one okay
I haven't been able to find that guy's toe though.
I'm...
Wait.
Oh.
Guys, I found that guy's toe.
It was hidden in plain.
It's hidden in plain sight.
The duck exhibit.
There's something in here?
Hey, buddy.
You're scaring me.
You're making me nervous.
If you gotta let it out, just let it out.
I'll clean it up.
it's okay not feeling well it's okay also it's like a
missing duck but maybe it's fine
you carried the toe right there at the beginning no way i
really did that's so funny i did it to myself all right
there's one last thing here what are you doing you silly cat
You were such a goober.
You were such a silly goober boy.
Come here.
Lay down.
There you go.
We're so close, you guys.
I mean, we could still leave, but we won't get 100%.
And that's the worst thing that could happen.
It's just something in this room.
Yeah.
And now, at this point, all the paintings are on.
And none of them seem crooked.
use your special eyes I am someone said it was a crooked
painting yeah but I'm looking at them
the second hand I'm wondering if it's something silly like
something was in the correct place and I pushed it out of
the correct place you know that
so it's like impossible to know You know what I mean?
But I don't think it's any of these.
I don't think it's the duck room.
It's this room.
The duck room is its own room.
Like...
These look fine, but...
This is its own room.
The benches don't let me move them.
Why does this feel impossible?
I'm using my cleaner sense literally like nothing is coming
up except cash baby that's cool this is tough this is like
actually finding a needle in a haystack
why is there a little blood thing in the corner there that
was weird this is so tough
I don't know.
Game is gas-lamping you?
There's only 36 pieces of furniture to move back in place.
What?
That can't be right.
Wait, the number goes up.
Do you see that?
The number goes up every time.
Yeah, the counter keeps...
i think the i think the game is bugged i think it's bugged
that's how i feel about that oh my gosh we were running
around like a chicken oh my gosh there's nothing there's
nothing there's really nothing well boys i guess we just
head out if it says i didn't get perfect i say screw you i
think we got it all wait does this have a it has like
something written on it why are all these so heavy
Okay, well
Some people report a bug in this map for statues
We did One of the paintings lit up It did not because we got
a hundred percent score, baby Yeah Yeah Take that, Jolie
Yeah all right all right and all this cat 24 000 i still
don't think we were paid enough for that but you know 16
skill points and we got all the secrets we got everything we
got everything oh steal 50 000 was an achievement i just god
holy moly our place is looking so nice oh we stole the
dinosaur that's too cute
wow we've redecorated so nicely hello dexter don't worry
dexter ladies are more into good boys good boys ladies are
more into good boys our place is looking so So nice.
We got a little heater.
Oh, wait.
Did we replace the...
Ew.
Did we replace the floors?
Wow.
Look, we've almost got all the cassettes.
Oh, that was me.
Okay.
Is my sleeve hitting your ear?
Okie doke.
go to bed and wow wow you're okay you're okay we gave her a
laptop even fancy
yeah i think our big big jim's warehouse i've been working
so hard for this moment and now everything is finally ready
thought you could get away with killing my daughter no no no
cleaner it's time you learned your lesson
whoa so someone's going after big Jim our wife who is that
in the corner is it okay to keep doing this Dexter working
in such a despicable profession.
Oh.
How can I even put a stop to this?
Who is that?
We have our Oshi up there.
Oh, shoot.
We play Oblivion.
Moshi-moshi.
It's Jin.
Some lazy workers tried to screw me over.
So now they are dead.
of dealing with that shit again.
Do you know how hard it is to find loyal employees nowadays?
So how's it gonna be, Kavalski?
Are you more loyal than the guys whose corpses you'll be
collecting?
I believe so.
Check your email for details.
Each one of your tasks makes me more of a corpse, Jim.
Zoro, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Loyalty to your country or loyalty to Big Jim.
I have a feeling this warehouse is going to be our biggest
yet.
These are the final weeks.
Hi, Dad.
The doctors told me that these are the final weeks of my
treatment.
I'm excited but also nervous.
I know it's not over yet, but I can see the finish line.
I'm trying to stay positive and take it one day at a time.
I can't wait to be home with you and I know Dexter is
probably waiting for me too.
Love you.
Our daughter's coming home.
13 bodies big big size there's a warehouse to clean outside
the town freaking riot some guy infiltrated the premises and
incited other workers to take over the factory ungrateful
bastards disloyalty is a deadly disease luckily I've got
some of my guys nearby it didn't take long to come and put
them in their place.
If workers don't want to work, they might as well be dead.
Oh, that does not bode well for us, I think.
This place should be easy to clean.
Remote location, access to running water, almost no
furniture.
Okay, that's kind of nice.
Accepted.
Big gin.
Right wife.
Okay.
It's kind of scary out, though.
It's kind of scary out.
Let's go take a...
Oh, wait.
Let's get some perks first.
Oh, whoops.
M.
Let's get our perks first.
And, uh, I don't remember what I was working towards, I'll
be honest.
Well, we have 29 points!
Wait, did I not spend it before?
That's kind of crazy.
UV lamp Increased garbage detection range Increased bag
capacity And then this one is Increases the maximum number
of combined garbage bags For three detergents Let's do that
one And then we'll do Increased power of detergents by 10
Increases power of detergents by 25 If they are not
duplicated Wait Increase this power of detergents by 10 if
there's only one type.
No, we'll do the...
We'll do this one.
Increase quantity.
Unlimited capacity.
Let's do, um...
Cool down reduction.
And then, no cool down.
Cleaner sense can also highlight pieces of missing
furniture.
I needed that last...
I needed that last time, for real.
Alchemist is busted Wait What's that one?
Oh, the alchemist?
Yeah, that's the one I did, right?
Yeah.
Good call on the bucket.
Thank you.
You thought you did, but you didn't.
Oh, for skills?
Oh no!
We could have been We could have been awesome.
Getting the last detergent is also great.
The unlimited?
I mean, I guess it will make me be less like stingy about
it, so we'll do it.
And then...
I don't know.
You can use Cleaner Sense without limits.
So we'll do... Wait.
Limits is like the reduction, right?
Because I don't really have a limit at the moment.
So I feel like increased duration is better than no
cooldown, right?
Because then What if I get the cool down reduction?
Then it doesn't do anything if I get no cool down.
I didn't save my... Yes, I did.
I saved.
I saved for the water one.
This one I'm still trying to decide.
Yeah, we want bigger bags, too.
I think that's a big deal.
But if I do this...
The missing furniture...
Nah, we'll do increased duration and no cool down.
Okay.
And then we'll go to tools.
We'll do uh...
increased bag capacity
increased garbage range and combined bags oh yeah I don't
use my pressure washer watch so I'm not gonna worry about it
and now we're working we could have used all of this for for
last one oh well that's okay for the last map it would have
been great to have all of this but holy moly that one
sounded scary um we're not gonna do this next map because i
do have to go get ready for concerts and and other things so
um uh but i do want to go look at it so we'll go look at it
real quick call in dead dorko thank you we're always glappy
It'll be a long night.
You have no idea, Kowalski.
Uh-huh.
This was the moment when Big Jim was at his weakest.
With so many people going after his ass, he needed to make a
choice.
If not, there probably wouldn't be anything else to
anticipate, but his imminent downfall.
Oh, sorry.
I wanted to read before...
I'm so glad the museum was just glitched.
Nice work making everything clean.
Good luck and have fun with everything tonight.
Thargo, thank you so much for the big.
Thank you, I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Ozzy!
I just got a kitty yesterday and he is absolutely thriving.
His name is Cyrus.
Oh, I'm glad to hear your kitty is also doing well.
Congrats on getting a kitty.
Oh, shoot, he's talking.
Next to Cleaner, I should definitely add electrician to my
CV.
No, we missed what he said.
Oops, sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Valerius, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Sorry, guys.
When I have to...
I'm in borderless mode, yet the game does not like me to go
out.
Good luck on the concert and other secrets.
Thank you.
The plot thickens.
I'm actually invested in this.
Looking forward to the finale.
Yes, we'll have to do the finale next time.
Next time, guys.
But let's just take a little bit of a sneak peek in what
we've got going on here, right?
closed i need to go another way okay
purple for lights yellow for crane blue for hatches green
for fast belt and orange for elevator miss rash raspberry
oh no need to look for the bodies
why is it so scary the bodies down this hatch if i can get
it open oh Oh lordy, okay.
Okay.
We'll just, uh...
We'll handle this, um...
Next time!
Well, if you want to keep cleaning, the nightmare versions
of levels are basically...
Oh, you're okay.
Are you okay?
Alright, man.
Are you alright, buddy?
You something bothering you?
Are you okay?
or yeah i'm so sorry i wish i could keep playing but
unfortunately i do have to go so thank you, guys thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you so much for watching and
hanging out with me Really appreciate it!
Bye-bye!